the newest trailer for Avengers endgame
hits in the early minutes of Super Bowl
53 and for most fans watching what
turned out to be one of the more
mediocre big games in recent memory it
was probably one of the few actual
highlights of the night the only real
complaint we have about the 30-second
spot
it just wasn't long enough steel with
such a short running time the trailer
was packed with details and moments that
seem to hide plenty of significance
while we can't know for sure where any
of these scenes might truly mean until
the movie comes out in late April we can
definitely make some educated or not so
educated guesses here are some of the
smaller details and the big games
Avengers endgame trailer that you might
have missed potential spoilers ahead
first the trailer runs through ten shots
of MCU characters who's in this blink
and you'll miss it line up starting at
the top we see the wasp Nick Fury
spider-man Doctor Strange Falcon Scarlet
Witch star-lord Groot Drax Gamora and
rocket black panther and a couple
members of the dora milosh a the Winter
Soldier and the vision with the
exception of rockets and maybe those two
guards sharing the seamless T'Challa all
of these characters were killed in
infinity war either after the decimation
or directly at Thanos his hands at first
it seems that these images simply pay
tribute to the characters who died in
the previous movie but there might be
more going on here all the scenes are
rendered in black and white and red
symbolically red can represent life and
death being easily associated with blood
you know the stuff you need to keep
inside your body to not die but this is
a trailer for a movie involving Infinity
stones and the red ones the reality
stone there's been tons of speculation
that time travel will factor into the
plot of Avengers endgame but could these
red huge shots actually signify that the
reality stone will be the key to their
resurrection who needs time travel if
you can just ask the reality stone to
make some dead people alive again we
also see Clint Barton bathed in red
light in the trailer and we saw the dead
Gamora in an orange light which many
fans speculate to be her living inside
the soul stone in infinity war let's put
this theory in the may be category the
trailer officially kicks off with a shot
of the Statue of Liberty well that's
usually a powerful symbol in film
standing for freedom or America in
general the details surrounding the
statue are what seemed to be most
significant it doesn't take long to
realize that something looks up about
the area surrounding
the island it's practically choked with
boats and ships for those of you who
don't stare lovingly at photos of
Liberty Island every day you may not
realize that this isn't something that
happens often or really ever compare the
shot in the trailer to this photo of
Liberty Island on a typical day as you
can see the amount of boats dock there
goes from a whole lot to exactly zero
the implication here seems to be the
utter desolation Thanos his snap from
the end of Avengers infinity war has
caused on the rest of the world people
are fleeing their home cities now
probably rendered completely broken due
to half the population blinking out of
existence and are heading towards New
York for refuge the image we get in the
trailer makes sense too since the
decimation probably destroyed air travel
throughout the world after world's
pilots and air traffic controllers are
all gone right so instead people are
getting on boats and sailing toward the
most easily identifiable port of entry
they can find the giant green lady
holding a torch right outside of
Manhattan in a brief but significant
moment from the trailer we get to see
Tony Stark and nebula working together
on something the last time we saw those
two it seemed like they were stranded in
space together on a spaceship stark was
recording a sad message for his ladylove
Pepper Potts or nebula was just creeping
through the ship now we get a clearer
glimpse of the two of them side-by-side
working on well again we still don't
know what it is since it's out of frame
but we can hazard a few guesses it could
be repairs to the ship which would
enable it to get wherever they're going
more quickly maybe they're working on
fixing up a suit of Ironman armor which
got busted in the fight against Thanos
or maybe get some other thing we don't
know about
either way the most important revelation
here is that we know for sure that Stark
and nebula are putting their skills
together to figure out how to not die in
the cold cold vacuum of space there are
a couple scenes in the trailer there are
conspicuous by what we don't say as we
know by now what movie trailers may show
us previews of what we'll see when the
movie arrives but they'll just as often
focus the scenes they depict in order to
keep surprises at a maximum the trailer
for infinity war showed Hulk running
behind the rest of the Avengers in
Wakanda and we all know that Hulk never
showed up during the fight scene in the
finished film the new trailer for
endgame could be pulling the same
switcheroo
early in the trailer we see a shot of
Black Widow Captain America Bruce Banner
and war machine walking outside of
Avengers
quarters with a big old blank space for
a fifth character would seem to fit
easily another shot later shows the
Avengers in profile lined up with yet
another space for an apparently missing
character if we assume that this is an
example of Marvel Studios miss directing
our attention to keep certain spoilers
off-screen who could these missing
characters be if we believe these open
spaces point to some hidden characters
there are a few distinct possibilities
for who Marvel might be keeping under
wraps
we know that Hawkeye is back in action
in endgame as he shows up another point
in the trailer so it seems unlikely that
he'd have been erased from these scenes
but we still haven't caught sight of the
Incredible Hulk even though we have seen
banner could the Hulk have been
separated from banner in this movie
which has happened before in the comics
we also know that Gwyneth Paltrow will
be an Avengers end game to reprise her
role as Pepper Potts it's not crazy to
believe that Potts will take on the role
of rescue an identity she's taken on in
the comics while wearing one of Starks
suits of Iron Man armor seeing Potts in
an Avengers group shot would be a huge
spoiler so it makes sense that Marvel
would want to keep that particular plot
beat under its heart however there's an
even likely a person to have been erased
from the trailer it's very very likely
that the missing hero is Captain Marvel
whose debut movie is set to hit theaters
about a month before Avengers and game
drops we know from the end of infinity
war that Captain Marvel will be
important in this new film since the
logo appears on Nick Fury's pager just
after he gets dusted but what other
presence has Captain Marvel having this
new trailer surprisingly the answer is
lobsters yes that's right lobsters in
one of the few shots featuring rocket
the only surviving member of the
guardians of the galaxy seems to reveal
a couple of interesting details about
his possible location he opens up an old
wooden door with a shot of a rocky shore
behind him along with a couple of
lobster traps so what right well most of
the country's lobsters come from Maine
and according to the life of Captain
Marvel comic book miniseries from 2018
Carol Danvers considers Harpswell Maine
her home away from home
meanwhile the characters fictional
biography has a born in Boston a New
England location that could certainly
have a few lobster traps lying around as
well
in either case when you add in the fact
that Captain Marvel is a spacefaring
hero and rocket the alien racoon seems
to be the character hanging out on
Beach it seems clear that Marvel's
hinting at captain Marvel's impending
arrival to save the day
Thor's whereabouts leave us with a lot
more guesswork than Rockets
we only get a couple of solo shots of
the Thunderer in the trailer ones a
close-up of his face while the next shot
shows him in silhouette at the mouth of
some sort of cable structure in the
distance we see the green of trees and
what looks like a hill or a mountain the
cave mouth itself feels unnatural and
potentially man-made so where is he
there are a number of possibilities but
like guessing what stark and nebula are
up to all we can do is speculate wildly
the colors of the landscape seem to look
a bit like Wakanda the cave likewise
could be some kind of base of operations
for the doora milosh a we know a Calle
was left alive at the end of infinity
war even if the continued existence of
T'Challa sister Shuri is in doubt
perhaps however this shot comes from
wherever Thanos ended up at the end of
infinity war the cave mouth or maybe
spaceship doesn't seem familiar at first
glance and we don't yet know enough
about where fallows retired but plot
wise it makes a lot of sense before to
visit his former foe so he could
retrieve the Infinity Gauntlet and undo
the noses damage of course we know that
it got fried right after the snap in the
last movie so the sad look on his face
could indicate a dead end when James war
machine Rhodes and Scott ant-man Lang
last met it was as enemies in Captain
America Civil War the two characters
took up opposite sides of the super
heroic conflict and we've never seen
them interact as anything other than
enemies in fact Ant Man and Captain
America basically threw a truck full of
gasoline at the guy throw it at this
now come on
needless to say the two of them didn't
have the kind of introduction that makes
for friendship
however we know for sure that both
characters will have important parts to
play an end game especially when ant-man
drives up in his aunt van at the end of
the first trailer Marvel Studios release
for the film the new trailer doesn't
give us much but we do see the pair
standing side by side getting suited up
and ready for action it stands to reason
that whatever beef these two had with
each other has been sufficiently
squashed at least into reality and/or
the timeline gets reset by the end of
the movie Captain America is pretty and
extra Cobley linked to his famous shield
but believe it or not he hasn't held the
thing up since the end of Captain
America Civil War he was rocking a
different shield entirely in infinity
war sort of a triangular black buckler
that was provided by T'Challa in Wakanda
but in this new trailer for endgame we
got a shot of what seems to be inside of
Captain America's classic shield the
circumstances of him reclaiming this
weapon are a big question mark last time
we saw it was when he threw it at Tony
Stark's feet after the two of them
finished fighting in Civil War
[Music]
maybe cap swung by tony's empty
penthouse to pick it up or maybe this is
yet more grist for the mill when it
comes to the constant time trouble
theories that continue to follow this
movie regardless of how he gets his
hands on it everyone knows just one
thing
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]